-Our next guest is
a very funny comedian and actor,
as well as the co-host
of the hit podcast
"Las Culturistas."
His album "Have You Heard
of Christmas?" is out now.
Please welcome back
to the show our friend
Matt Rogers, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hi.
-We were in sync there.
-You were very good.
A lot of times a guest
will try to do that,
they'll try to sync up with
the drummer and it ends badly.
-Can I tell you what it is?
-What is it?
-Jennifer Hudson was just
out here,
so it's very musical,
the vibe.
-The vibe. She left a little bit
of the musical vibe here.
-100%, I'm soaking it up.
Can you believe that?
I'm on the show,
and so is she
and I'm selling the album?
-Very weird.
-I can't.
It's not right,
but it is okay.
-[ Laughing ] It is?
-I did -- I did sing part
of her song to her.
-Backstage?
-Yeah.
-Now, that's not
technically allowed.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
But I'll say...
Does anyone know the song
"Spotlight" by Jennifer Hudson?
[ Cheers and applause ]
The real ones are here.
So there's,
like a call and response,
and she did the call
and response.
-And did you warn
her in advance,
or did she just know what to do?
-She wasn't warned,
I was here.
[ Laughter ]
She probably should have been,
to be honest with you.
-So did you have a very --
Was it a wonderful moment?
Would you say it was a...?
-It was incredible,
and it was kind of
everything I ever wanted,
because I'm going to tell you,
when she got voted off
"American Idol,"
that was the first time
I ever knew
what it felt like
to be truly radicalized.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Like, I remember
she got voted out
and I had aunts calling me
that night, like, what happened?
And I was like,
I don't know, Aunt Maureen.
I'm trying to figure it
out myself.
And so then I started
to from that point on,
I would vote politically.
Like, I'd vote for everyone
but the person I wanted out.
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah.
I didn't vote for my favorites.
I targeted people who were
messing the show up for me.
-Wow.
That's fantastic.
-I was like
the original Kornacki.
-Wow. So she basically taught
you the value of democracy?
-Exactly.
And thank you, Jennifer.
You've given us so much.
-So, this is -- this is a...
Oh, wait, before I ask
about the album...
-Yeah, put that away.
-...but you were at BravoCon.
-Yeah.
-So BravoCon is a real
big old thing now in Vegas.
-It's one of the realest,
biggest old things now.
-And how did you end up
moderating a panel?
-Well, Seth, I'm I have
a sick disease
where I'm absolutely obsessed
with all those women there.
By the way,
their names are Ubah,
Jessel, Brynn, Erin and Sai,
if that means nothing to you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Real ones
are really here tonight.
But it wasn't even just that.
It's kind of like a great
mystery how I'm alive.
I saw Usher Friday night,
did BravoCon Saturday,
and then Adele
Saturday night.
-That's great.
-And somehow I sit here.
-I'm so...
Yeah, it's amazing
that you made it out.
-And the craziest thing
was BravoCon.
-Yeah,
It's -- I'm telling you.
I was like, if I get murdered,
it was the Teresa Giudice fans.
[ Laughter ]
-I think that goes
without saying.
-Well, yeah.
-I don't even watch those shows
and I know that one.
-And you know
the household name.
No, but it was fun.
It was -- it was a celebration.
-This is a celebration
as well of Christmas.
Now, this started as a bit,
but I want to know,
these songs are very funny,
but they're also good songs.
-Thank you.
-So they're catchy,
fun Christmas songs.
But what, in the beginning
of this idea,
what part of the seed
of making an album
like this was funny to you?
-So basically, I think
it was just this idea
that every pop star,
like, really loves Christmas.
Like, that ain't true.
You want the money, girl?
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
-And so I thought --
I think it was like...
And I don't doubt that Mariah
really loves Christmas.
-Yeah.
-I'm talking about
Mariah Carey, of course.
-Yeah, yeah, of course not.
Not one of the lesser Mariah.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
But I was watching an interview
with her
and I think, like,
the interviewer kind of said,
like the quiet part out loud.
She was like, "Wow,
you making money every year."
-And I was like, "Wow."
Like, we sort of really revealed
the capitalism of it all there.
-Yeah.
-And I thought that was
maybe the funniest thing
I'd ever heard.
By the way,
Mariah is on my sock.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And she gets --
-It's like
the Wendy Williams shoe cam.
[ Laughter ]
But no, I think
I was just, like,
I think that is the funniest
thing I've ever heard.
Like, this idea that, like,
Christmas is the last vestige
of the monoculture.
And if you get in there
and you do a good job,
you can kind of...
-You can get paid every year.
-I mean, this is my second year
here for the Christmas stuff.
-So it's working out
pretty well.
-It's working on you.
-I do want to note...
It's 100% working.
I mean, I didn't realize --
I didn't realize
until this moment that I'd been
had, but I am.
[ Laughter ]
When a lot of people --
-Think politically, again.
-A lot of people argue about
when the Christmas season
officially starts.
-Yeah.
-Your actual, the special,
this album's from --
Last year
was a little bit closer
to Christmas, correct?
When it came out?
-Yeah, I think it came
out early December.
-Okay,
so this is early November.
When do you actually think
the season starts?
-So I started recording this
in late June,
and my one day off
was the 4th of July.
I was at like
a gay party in L.A.
Everyone was in Speedos.
You're like, what are you doing?
I'm like, "I'm doing
a Christmas album."
But I think it kind of starts
whenever Mariah says,
but this year it's not
just Mariah, it's also Cher.
-Okay.
-So Cher and I obviously
got together at one of our
weekly dinners...
-Of course.
-...and we were like
is this the year for us?
And we decided yeah,
but she announced
hers like first week
of September.
-Yeah.
-And I was like, are we late?
They were like, she's early.
-Okay, gotcha.
Now, do you think Cher
jumped the gun a little bit
because she was worried
about competing with yours?
-I think she's incredibly
threatened by me.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And she should be.
-Yeah.
You do --
You do have a song --
-That's the pull quote.
Like, none --
none of the rest of it
makes the interview.
I'm just now -- it's now
Teresa Giudice fans
and Cher fans trying to kill me.
-Oh, yeah.
Now, you don't know.
-Horrified
-Now the detectives
are going to be like,
"It's a coin flip, sarge."
-Bring all the ladies in
for questioning.
-You -- you have a song about
how Christmas
is the horniest time
of the year?
-It is?
-Yeah, and that's nice,
because I feel like nobody
ever points that out.
-Yeah, I have a song.
-Yeah.
-That's really why I'm here
is because Mariah says
what she says about Christmas,
Cher says what she says,
and I'll say all the gay stuff.
they can't say.
-You're brave enough
to say the
things they won't.
-I can be described as brave.
-Yeah.
-Like, when I sang to
Jennifer Hudson backstage.
-Yeah, that was pretty brave.
-But basically I have a song
called "Also It's Christmas,"
and it's about
when you're, like,
partying in the club
around the holiday
and then you have to sort of
contend with the fact that,
like, you go outside and it's
like candy canes and stuff.
-Yeah.
-Because in the club
it's kind of always the club.
-Yeah.
-And then you get home,
and if you're lucky enough
to bring someone home,
it's like,
I guess you have to creep
by like your sister
and her kids staying with you.
-Yeah. That's less...
Right,
-...less horny.
I've also, like, I have --
I have seen, I mean, I have --
This has been true.
When people are at home
for Christmas,
that's when they get
horny in the DMs.
-Oh, interesting.
-I have sealed the deal
with many people
who were bored at home.
-Gotcha.
-Who just kind of knew
I would respond.
-Okay.
-And they were right.
-So if this is like
a Christmas Eve sealing
of the deal,
is that to be arranged
after the holidays conclude,
or is the sealing of the deal
take place on the eve?
-It's usually --
So usually you're busy
on Christmas Eve
and Christmas Day.
-Yeah.
-And then there's that like
two-day period
where you're kind
of still
at your parents house.
-Yeah.
-And you're like...
[ Laughter ]
And that's when the phone
comes out and you're like,
"Hey, dude, looking good."
Like, the lag.
The response, "You too, bro."
I don't know why we're
talking like straight guys.
The gay guys kind of do do that.
-I will say,
as you're doing this,
I'm like,
"I think I could do this."
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
Can I say, Seth, you'd be
a huge hit with gay guys.
-Thank you.
So it's like basically, like,
talking about fantasy football,
but for hooking up.
-It's -- it's incredibly
similar to that.
Think politically everyone.
-[ Laughs ]
Can you tell me about the song
"God's Up To His Tricks!?"
-Yeah.
So I...
[ Laughter ]
-There's a song...
-I have a song --
I have called
"God's Up To His Tricks!"
-Also, you also have one
called "Lube For The Sleigh."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Should we just go
track by track?
-Yeah.
-So "Lube For The Sleigh"
is about how I don't know
if you guys realize this,
but Santa, he doesn't go back
to, like,
refill the big bag of gifts.
He has to put all those gifts
in his one big bag,
so I feel like what he obviously
has to have happen
is he has to lube up
all the gifts for the big bag
so they fit.
-Oh, interesting.
And nobody asks why
Santa has so much lube.
Only Mrs. Claus knows.
-Okay, gotcha.
So maybe the whole,
the getting the gifts in a bag
is like a cover story.
-Maybe.
-Maybe the elves are like,
"What's all this lube?"
And he was like,
"Oh, I don't go back."
-Exactly.
-Yeah.
-But then I also...
That's -- I just want to make
one big trip.
[ Laughter ]
And then
"God's Up To His Tricks!"
is just about how -- I remember
I think I was --
I think I was hanging out with
Bowen and we were in traffic,
and I was like
"God really got up to his
tricks today with this traffic."
And that just kind of came out
of my mouth, and I was like,
oh, so now
when anything good or bad
happens to me,
that's blind faith,
that's God just getting up
to his little tricks.
-Yeah.
-And so I wrote
a song about that.
It's in the -- it's in the style
of like a musical theater,
Andrew Lloyd Webber.
And "Lube For the Sleigh"
is a disco song, by the way.
I know that that's --
that seemed like --
-I think,
if given the choice,
we would have got that right.
-Right, right, right, exactly.
You're coming on my podcast.
-I am.
So you mentioned Bowen.
You and Bowen Yang have a --
How long have you --
how many episodes
have you done
of "Las Culturistas?"
-Oh, God.
We're coming up on 400 episodes.
-That is amazing.
-Yeah.
-Congratulations.
That's really, really cool.
-Thank you.
And you know what's funny?
Like, we started it in 2016
and we thought we were
so late on podcasts.
This is so lame.
We were like, this sucks.
We're doing a podcast now.
It's like over.
Now, everyone was --
I was, you know, Hillary,
Hillary's got a pod.
-But, yeah, you guys were like
front runners on podcasts.
Congratulations.
-Which we never would have
known,
and by the way, it's a big deal
for you booking our pod
because we don't allow
straight men on.
-Really?
-No, it's you and Will Ferrell,
and we had to let him on
because he begged.
-Oh, wow.
-It was pathetic
-Based on this, I think I know
how to talk like gay men.
I'd be like, "What's up, bro?
How's it going?"
Like I said...
[ Laughter ]
All of a sudden
I get in your DMs.
-Ding, ding, ding.
Hey, what a delight
to have you here.
Congrats on the --.
I can't wait to do your podcast.
-Matt Rogers, everybody,
"Have You Heard
It's Christmas?" out now.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night.